depuis l'attaqué au couteau qui a fait
trois morts à nice le 29 octobre dernier
paris attend des actes des actes celle
de la part notamment de la tunisie d'où
est originaire l'assaillant présumé
le jeune homme de 21 ans est arrivé en
france en passant par l'italie
quelques minutes quelques heures après
cet ignoble attentat de nice vos
services ont apporté de façon
considérable les informations à la
république française pour pouvoir mieux
comprendre ce qui s'était passé j'ai des
choses c'est à dire que nous combattons
ensemble
évidemment ce qui a déjà très largement
frappés votre pays à plusieurs reprises
et la france était à vos côtés qui a
frappé les pays
évidemment concernées en europe la
france bien sûr l'autriche
il n'y a pas si longtemps qui est une
idéologie
paris veut expulser une vingtaine de
tunisiens soupçonnait d'être radicaliser
qui ont purgé leur peine de prison en
france
tunis se dit prêt à accueillir ses
ressortissants mais sous certaines
conditions
nous sommes toujours prêts à recevoir
n'importe quel tunisien mais cela doit
être fait selon les conditions et les
règlements cité dans le droit
international dont le plus important est
la préservation de la dignité du
tunisien ainsi que l'autorisation pour
les tunisiens expulsés de france de
pouvoir bénéficier de tous leurs droits
un tunisien radicalisées a déjà été
renvoyé cette semaine lors de sa visite
en algérie ces prochaines heures gérald
darmanin doit présenter une liste de
ressortissants algériens en situation
irrégulière en france et jugé dangereux
le ministre français de l'intérieur
s'entretiendra d'ailleurs avec son
homologue kamel
jaune et le ministre des affaires
étrangères sabri boukadoum italie
tunisie algérie et malte cette tournée
en méditerranée étaient prévus avant
l'attaqué de nice mais face à
l'actualité
paris tente de poser ses conditions au
nom de la lutte contre le terrorisme
le locataire de la place beauvau se met
dans la peau d'un équilibriste montrer
que la france reste ferme sur la
question de l'immigration et de la
radicalisation sans froisser ses alliés
sur le plan diplomatique